[Music]
any uh Homo
sapiens in the audience raise your hands
got it
just turn to your neighbor introduce
yourself Homo sapiens Homo sapiens Homo
sapiens Homo sapiens Homo sapiens it's
all Homo sapiens out here right why we
Prevail haven't we prevailed we have
done a pretty damn good job of
prevailing shall sh shall we just all
acknowledge for a
moment why is that is it an ego thing is
it a biology thing is it a natural
selection thing I mean
the other hominids what a bunch of
losers
God Meander
TOS oh they have not a chance in the
world right I mean homos
sapiens of course we would Prevail um
but there's actually a very interesting
scientific set of reasons why we
prevailed it's not fully known why PR we
prevailed it's a bit of a mystery why we
prevailed as a species because 100,000
years ago there were all kinds of
hominids roaming around I mean can you
imagine a planet where there were
multiple species of humans all
cooperating together different
capabilities different sort of
physiologies physi you know every
everyone sort of coexisting on the same
yeah that's ridiculous that's no way
that would work with homo saens around
right um we had to dominate and we
prevailed what happened 100,000 years
ago or more the fossil record tells one
story our genetics tell another story
our physiology tells another story and
the climate also tells part of the story
of why Homo sapiens is the only homed
species left on the planet and let's
begin with a little video that tells us
a little bit about how we got here let's
listen
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
so that's pretty clear right yeah no
further explanation needed there um
let's take take a look at what this
subject actually means and what the
science the current science in
paleontology says about why we prevailed
where we came from and what happened to
all the other folks our first
participant hailes from the University
of California Santa Cruz where he's
peering deep into prehistory through a
lens no one has looked through until now
he's studying the neander genome his
work could reveal who we met and mingled
with there's a scandal as we spread
across the globe please welcome Ed
green
our next guests Decades of research and
fieldwork have brought a new
understanding of when and where human
cognition developed she also argues that
there were critical social networks
throughout the world of humanid long
before Facebook please welcome Allison
[Applause]
Brooks I could say um MC Jagger okay but
I won't our next guest is a
distinguished two-time pullit surprise
winner who has been called one of the
Century's most influential scientists
and thinkers he is an evolutionary
biologist at Harvard and his newest book
The Social conquest of Earth strives to
answer the biggest questions of The
Human Condition where did we come from
what are we and where are we going
please welcome Mick Jagger eio
Wilson
and our final guest Hales from the
Natural History Museum in London one of
the world's leading
paleoanthropologists his doctoral work
shows that humans were not descended
from theander tals his latest book Lone
survivors how we came to be the only
humans on Earth presents a new theory of
human Origins altogether please welcome
Chris
Stringer
so what a thrill to have you all here
and to really begin with the question of
100,000 years ago or whenever
uh how many different species were there
around and uh we'll slowly get to the
question of what became of them but uh
we live in a world of just a single
homed species uh what was it like a
100,000 years ago house well we had uh
Homo sapiens in Africa of a a somewhat
archaic version but nevertheless looking
very much like us we had neander tals in
Europe and Asia as far east as uh
usbekistan and probably all the way to
to Western the western edge of
Siberia and then um thanks to genetic
research we had uh intimations that
there was at least another species in uh
somewhere in living somewhere in Asia
probably east Southeast somewhere like
that um that we know basically primarily
from their DNA and that's the denant and
then we had a little a very a dwarf
species of humans living on the island
of Flores in
Indonesia um that you may have heard
about as The Hobbit and that was a we
it's very interesting it's The Hobbit
part of the reason for calling it The
Hobbit is it's small but it also turns
out to have had enormous
feet
so an advantage or a disadvantage
enormous feet it was very unclear it
certainly didn't have very big territory
to travel around was on this little
island but how would you describe uh Ed
what was going on you know in your sort
of supposition about this particular
period were these groups competing or
were they just
uh I mean I surviving and we we think of
them as competing because you know
certain species survived certain species
did not well the um although temporarily
um they were around 100,000 years ago
there were many more players on the
scene um geographically they weren't at
least at that time probably living next
door to one another although in the
Middle East there could have been the
neander and humans there at the same
time later when humans um replaced
whatever archaic forms were in Africa
and migrated Out of Africa they came
into contact with these other groups who
had um their ancestors had earlier left
Africa and colonized Eurasia and um at
that time there could have been direct
competition what we know um for sure is
that there was at least some ad mixture
which is a fancy way of saying that
there was sex there was um hybrids uh
there were hybrid between um early
humans and the neander tals and these
denans and we know that because we find
the genes of neander tals and denans
within the genomes of people who are
alive today and we'll explore that in
just a moment when we try to examine the
genetic record but uh uh the question
really is where did people begin and why
did they move Chris is is there is there
a way of answering that question because
there must be many different reasons for
why certain populations seem to need to
move well yes I think one of the most
obvious ones is just the need for food I
mean people are often moving to
territories to follow the food um so in
Africa for example we know there have
been major climatic changes so at times
parts of Africa became very arid
populations would have had to have move
just to stay alive um and we know that
uh in some cases obviously they're
following migrating herds of animals so
we see here a possible representation of
the spread of humans uh Out of Africa um
and of course we don't know the precise
roots in many cases so there's there's a
leading idea that the movement of modern
humans Out of Africa towards Asia might
have actually gone along the coasts of
southern Asia which is bad news for the
archaeology because in the last 12,000
years the sea level has risen at the end
of the last ice age so many of the sites
that would record that are actually
under the sea now so possibly we don't
have as much evidence as you like and
this map a lot of this is based on
genetic data rather than really good
physical mapping of those dispersals now
I noticed that some of those blue lines
actually make it into the water which
would have implied that you know we're
not walking all the way to Australia for
instance or well there were at times of
course with the rise of the ice ages so
sea level at times was 120 M lower at
the peak of the ice ages so parts of
Southeast Asia that are now separated
Islands they would have been joined up
to each other so people would have been
able to make their way down Southeast
Asia but certainly to get to New guine
and Australia yes they would have needed
boats to get there eio Wilson does the
fossil record the genetic record all the
various paleontological evidence pools
that we have suggests that everything
Began in Africa and that hominids were
chased out of Africa and then began this
uh parallel evolution in these various
locations that we see on the map it was
a a very active theater of species
formation prior to that in Africa
uh so that it's not surprising that the
earliest the earlier forms the homo
erectus level had made it out for
example and had um probably formed new
species including quite possibly and
this could be ascribed even to an
earlier line that went out that's what
the geneticists have to work out uh the
uh the flues
people uh in Africa what we see
emerging uh as though we were explorers
as though my paleontologist and genetic
friends were explorers of the 19th
century first entering the Dark
Continent and working out the
distribution for the first times of new
species of birds and mammals uh they are
at a much slower Pace because it's takes
so much more effort to find fossils of
the right kind and right age to put the
picture together
but they are discovering one after the
other in Africa evidence of what we call
adaptive radiation now 100,000 years for
biologists considering the origin of
humanity uh is but yesterday when you go
back before say uh several hundred
thousand years and then uh up to seven
several million years we have U much
evidence of the first the ostop signes
that preceded homo and gave rise to it
in a fairly well in geologic time fairly
recent period uh we see in the aists for
example clear examp uh clear evidence of
uh this not only the
species uh evolving in a line certain
one species that involved in a line that
produced such but there was a radiation
of a variety of species as many as three
ostop the predecessors of um homo that
we are sort of limiting ourselves to
right now uh that coexisted maybe two
million years ago so this is the kind of
evidence in addition to dissent and then
uh species formation in more recent homo
homo period uh that um Africa
was there was a u a major Center of
Rapid Evolution and very extensive
evolution of what must have been a
fairly um a very a fairly um successful
group even though in lower populations
Allison does it seem as though those
groups that IO Wilson is talking about
were competing directly in in Africa or
did certain groups have a extraordinary
Stroke of Luck and benefited from either
some sort of climate geography that
benefited one group over the other and
that the the the migration patterns for
instance uh were they exclusively
motivated by uh climate or again did the
groups that chose to go to New Guinea uh
have extraordinary amount of luck versus
groups that chose to go to uh you know
Canada
well who um if you're if you're starting
out in Africa first of all I don't think
they probably didn't even know they were
leaving unless they were crossing water
um I think we're not talking about
setting off on an Epic Journey that's
going to take you to the Americas um and
the other thing is that to realize that
after about 1.2 1.3 million years ago we
only have evidence of basically one
species at a time in Africa although
there are some intimations that there
were other more archaic species just as
there were neander tals and denans and
modern humans in Eurasia for a while we
think that when there were modern humans
in Africa there were probably also
archaic ones and Chris discovered
sometimes you make your discoveries in a
museum and not in a not in an
archaeological site and he discovered an
archaic fossil in his own collection go
where the fossils are right um but so I
think that the uh the climate certainly
had a factor but also the when you have
to realize that people didn't
leave Africa in the sense of they
abandoned Africa because Africa was such
a bad place to live they continued to
live there in large numbers but they
grew their numbers to the extent that
they expanded the species expanded Out
of Africa we're talking about our
species now at the expense of other
species for reasons we can we can argue
about but so migration was a result of
success in the original location um Ed
are there particular theories as to why
certain groups didn't make it why
certain groups didn't migrate or uh why
certain groups that chose to migrate
didn't find success in the locations
that they went so do you mean the
nanders why they who the various groups
that began to proliferate you know along
this uh blue line here well we um I'm
not sure exactly what the question is
but the um what we know as Chris um
pointed out the we we see the earliest
routes of humans around South Asia and
very early on reaching the islands
around Oceana and then slower uh filling
in Mainland Asia and filling in Europe
and replacing the other forms that were
there um the talk about the replacement
though what does that mean exactly they
competed directly and then well we would
like to know this there there are um
precious few sites where there is um
evidence of cohabitation even um close
in time exactly what this it it's
something that um one can't help but
imagine what it must have been like but
real archaeological and fossil evidence
of of of humans archaic humans in the
Andals at the same place at the same
time interacting is um practically
absent but but the what we do know is
that there was some interaction we also
know from the genetic evidence looking
at the genetics of humans who are um
live today outside of Africa that there
was probably a single bottleneck that
everyone who is of non-african ancestry
is a little bit more related to everyone
else of non-african ancestry and that
this was one migration of what would
become a very successful group that that
outcompeted or um however one wants to
phrase that of the neander tals and the
denin and all other forms and and is the
sole
survivor how would you Chris describe
that bottleneck what do you think
happened where did it occur uh what
happened during that particular
bottleneck how many you know what was
the size of the various populations well
I think uh estimating population size is
really difficult geneticists do attempt
it and um I mean the data suggests that
all of these human forms um were at
incredibly low numbers by modern
standards so you know we're talking at
at best tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people scattered over very
large areas so and at times evidence
that some of these human groups came
down to just a few thousand breeding
individuals so the neand was from
genetic data towards the end of their
time even before modern humans arrived
and may have competed with them they
already you could say were an endangered
group their genetic diversity was very
low so this seems to have been happening
and uh you know I think many people have
said that you know if the proverbial
visitor from out space came to Earth
100,000 years ago they probably wouldn't
have singled any of these groups out as
as a as a likely candidate for global
domination with the numbers that were
around at that time and in terms of
competition and how they actually
interacted as Ed said we we have very
little data that they overlapped we we
guess they must have but we have very
little data on that and uh the views for
example of The Disappearance of the the
anals go from one view that well when we
met them we just had a great kind of
love in and traded and uh you know M and
we had a wonderful kind of party with
them and it was all great and and uh
peaceful and at The Other Extreme two
Spanish workers have just published The
View that we basically hunted and E them
to Extinction um now I think you know um
those are very extreme views I think the
truth's going to be somewhere in between
and in fact there won't be a single
reason why say the neand Discover
neander
recipes
well yeah there may have been advantages
in actually meeting ands uh of course
they would they had been evolving in
those conditions in Europe for hundreds
of thousands of years the denisovans we
assume have been evolving over in Asia
for hundreds of thousands of years so
possibly there were advantages in
actually meeting these people and
exchanging views and and possibly some
of the genetic exchanges were
advantageous to modern humans there's a
suggestion we got a quick fix by
interbreeding with these people to get
some immune reactions to local diseases
and conditions outside of Africa Allison
you it sounded like you had a comment
there yeah I think we need to also
realize that modern humans did leave
Africa more than once but it's only the
last departure that was really
successful so they because they do show
up in the Middle East around 100,000
years ago but then they're replaced in
the Middle East by neandertals after
that this is a good point and and when
we make figures like this to for simplif
to learn it it's good to draw a single
error arrow and and to learn episodes
but in fact the history is almost
certainly more complicated than that
that there would have been periods
during which people were migrating out
we know that few people are involved
because of the massive reduction in
genetic diversity that occurred with
that but any U sort of temporal arrow
drawing that one can do is is almost
certainly an oversimplification I had a
a question also for Chris so the um
the um as I understand it and this is
not really my field but the um fossil
record is a bit suggestive in that
neander tals are disappearing from the
fossil record in the same temporal and
spatial pattern that humans are coming
onto the scene is is there anything that
one can safely um a conclusion one can
draw from that what should one read into
that about how they were interact can I
just elaborate on that question so
you're you're asking the fossil record
shows that the population of TS was
declining at the same moment that the
population of of humans was ascending um
I'm asking this as is this a true thing
it's something that I have been taught
but and not necessarily even declining
it's hard to get a census number but
declining in the sense that it's going
to zero and there are none the last
neander TOS you find are the ones to the
West Grace yeah I think in terms of
where the last ones were obviously yes
there's a suggestion that they were
surviving down in Iberia Spain and so on
the longest but there are large areas of
Asia where we have very little data and
we know from DNA data now the neols got
to Southern Siberia so they might have
survived in Asia longer than we we know
about at the moment um but in terms of
um what what was leading to this
attrition if you like of neander numbers
um the climate was very unstable we know
this that that um the ice ages you know
obviously you get a massive ice Advance
about every 100,000 years but also there
are these very short-term fluctuations
that are poorly understood in terms of
the causes and so every few thousand
years the conditions in the North
Atlantic switch from being warm nearly
as warm as they are today to the
Atlantic being totally kind of frozen
over so this influenced certainly
Western Europe in a huge way um these
Millennial scale fluctuations and the
neand tiles were being hit by these
repeatedly every few thousand years the
climate rapidly swung to a relatively
warm condition and then a thousand years
later back to extreme cold so when it
warmed up they went North when it
suddenly froze they all died out in
those areas and survived clung on in the
South when modern humans came in
possibly during one of these brief warm
phases they started to get into NE anal
territories and then when things went
downhill that heightened the competition
that's how I kind of see it in those
extreme circumstances both populations
will be stressed and then the advantage
will be to the groups that can adapt
best to those CH rapidly changing
conditions and as Allison May point out
that's one of the things about modern
humans is our ability to change Behavior
rapidly uh compared with some of these
more archaic people all right we're
going to talk about behavior in a moment
let's finish this particular section EO
Wilson um by just sort of recapping so
essentially what the f fossil record
possibly shows us and as you say it's so
easy to oversimplify because of a
limited amount of data Ed uh but there
were many departures from Africa the
fossil record shows a lot of dead end
distributed around the globe of of
populations that attempted to succeed
and did not but that at a particular uh
point one of these migrations was
absolutely critical and as you say Chris
there was an encounter between neander
TOs and modern humans and the outgrowth
of that encounter is what we see in our
DNA evidence that's that's essentially
what we're talking about here Ed
anything to add to that uh well I tell
you what let's look uh let me just look
at this very briefly uh from the
biologist or evolutionary biological
point of view the U human evolution
which we see in fragmentary form do
suggest that we were evolving and that
we were speciating that is dividing into
species uh in a nonatypical
uh form uh when the um no wait a minute
nonatypical that would be I'm sorry in
atypical animals yeah you're right all
right so uh just uh yeah um that's
Harvard's speak Harvard speak yes it is
Harvard's speak um so uh what do we have
uh during the P scene that was critical
they there were immense climatic changes
from uh 2 and a half million years ago
to 11,000 years ago Africa went through
a series of of extreme drought periods
and uh most likely human popul s were
bottleneck they were driven into refugia
uh we know what some of those persistent
moist areas are where populations most
likely U Were maintained when you have
that kind of fragmentation of
populations then you have the first
stage for species formation and for
genetic
diversification generally of the kind
that allows the overall meta population
you know the many population together uh
to progress quite rapidly so in this
case the
pine uh the the crisis of the pine
climate uh had probably an important
driving force uh behind this and there
were multiple species and there are
three things that can happen when you
have more than one species it's very
possible that during the place of scene
there were
populations that became distinct species
and and met and we don't have uh
evidence of that yet that there were
that many species we have it further
back but not in this most recent period
within Africa so there are three things
that can happen one when two species
evolve from a single
stock uh in uh the a period when you
know geographic isolation due to the
climatic change occurs
then uh the two can and this I'm not
talking about animal and plant species
and why not this be the case for humans
uh they spread in the better time they
meet and they occupy enough of the same
Niche so that they stabilize alop Patria
that is in different ranges or one uh
replaces the other and that's what
appears to have happened substantially
or what could I certainly would have
happened before the pine in
um well maybe during the later periods
of the pine uh in the ostr Opus uh you
get what's called character displacement
the two meet and they're a little bit
different in their adaptations what they
eat where they live exactly and though
they might coexist and they tend to
displace one another in what they
have or evolve to utilize in the
environment they get different niches
and they can coexist evidently in the
last period in the spread from Africa in
that successful founder population
incidentally that's another principle
exemplified when you see populations
being introduced even in the modern era
when they're being introduced as
invasive species we see cases of
invasion followed by collapse of the
population and no longer the Po's longer
there then another one then another one
and then one takes and it goes well in
the case of uh
coexisting that's when you have multiple
species occurring when you have one
species replacing another that's just
one of a series of outcomes and suggests
that the species involved at least one
of them was so
variable and uh capable of competition
across many niches that it could
displace anything anywhere close go to
it surviv I think that's the pattern
that was following survival of the most
adaptable that's sort of the the
mechanism here we're going to talk about
that physiologically but just to one
sort of final Point uh takes off is that
Harvard speak
also yeah
Wilson takes off I like that yeah very
good I'm going to make that as a
ringtone on my cell phone I think um all
right let's look at the physiology here
for a moment how if if if we were as you
say Chris if aliens had landed on the
Planet they would have found these
pathetic humans and G well there's no
chance for these folks here uh and they
would have said the planet is going to
be inhabited by ants probably is what
that well you that's what you certainly
would have said but if we had been there
and seen these various species what
would we have seen in the physiology of
neandertals and some of the other uh
hominids as well as the modern uh
species and and what would the
advantages have been in brain size or
abdominal size Chris okay um well I
think we've got an image of couple of
sculls that we could put on here um
that'll come up hopefully okay there we
go so um this medical technique CT
scanning being applied to the fossils
and it's really given us a huge amount
of information about the anatomy of
these uh of these people that we just
didn't have before so even the inner ear
bones of neander now we we know what
they look like and they're actually
slightly distinct from from Modern human
ones so we've got a comparison here the
hyob against this skull from Africa
which I view as the ancestral species
for us and the neand and then a modern
human on the right there and we could
have picked any modern human that
happens to be an Australian but equally
it could have been an American an
African a European um an Asian so we can
see there at a glance the differences
between these two so the hyur against
skull is certainly thicker it's longer
and lower um the face is larger more
projecting um in the modern human a
globular brain case um the brow Ridge of
course massive in the hyberg Enis but
but very small in the modern human if we
had the lower jaw we would see the
hyberg Enis specimens have no Chin
whereas of course modern humans you know
we've all got chins it's a bit variable
I know if you look around but uh in
general so these features that we see on
the right there are the shared features
of our species and if we have the
skeleton there then as we'll see in a
minute the skeleton is lightly built now
in my view all of those shared features
of our species evolved in one place just
in Africa and then when we came out of
Africa that that pattern was exported as
we spread and of course it stayed behind
in Africa as well but if we look at you
know what was giving us our success well
okay there are some Clues obviously the
brain is somewhat larger maybe 10 to 20%
larger by the time you factor in that
hyob is had a bigger body size so
there's going to be a bigger brain
allowing for that modern humans
certainly have bigger brains but
detailed study shows that there are some
subtle differences in the frontal load
in modern humans and the parietal loes
the upper part of those is very expanded
in modern humans so these may be Clues
to something different in the brain
because what we'd love to know is what
the internal wiring of that brain's like
and we only have this very crude picture
of of the brain shape but it's certainly
different between the two and the fact
that our dentition is smaller our face
is smaller this suggests that you know
we're probably doing different things
with our food processing things
differently what we're eating is is
different um our our Jaws are not so
expanded our teeth are smaller so we're
probably processing our food more as
well and that also is energetically
advantageous the more processing you do
on the food before it gets into your
mouth that saves you energy of course
although doesn't it take energy to
process the food I mean if you're just
ripping it out of an anal yeah but but
you know if you can if process yeah but
if you want your kids to survive you can
process the food for them as well cuz
that's the most important thing is you
want the Next Generation to survive as
well and if we go on to the next image
we can just see these are the skeletons
yeah we can see a comparison here now of
a neand a composite skeleton of a neand
on the left there and a modern human and
you know the first thing to stress is
neiles are highly evolved humans they're
they're not missing links they walk up
right as well as we do they don't have
grasping big toes uh or anything like
that they're they're very evolved humans
but there are differences um you can see
there these are scale to the same size
the Neal body is much wider The Wider
shoulders wider hips
um a different shaped rib cage a barrel
shaped rib cage um very powerful upper
body so the anales were physically very
strong shorter and wider on average than
than the comparable modern human there
um so we in a sense in our skeletons
we're wimps so physically we didn't have
any advantage over the neander toes
quite the opposite in si what about
spell size well the neander toes had um
brains that were as big as ours um again
when scalled against body size they're
slightly smaller but they're still very
large brains but again in brain
proportions um it looks like the brain
in the ne anatar was more developed the
occipital loes are somewhat larger
relatively possibly that's the visual
areas might indicate Neal had had maybe
some more developed visual Acuity um but
the frontal loes some parts of the
frontal loes are reckoned to be somewhat
smaller in the neander tiles Allison how
do you formulate the question of what
advantages did the modern humans have
physiologically that allowed them to
compete more favorably with some of the
alternative species that were around at
the same time characteristics like wider
rib cage or uh uh larger skulls that can
be a positive and a negative I I don't
actually think they had many
physiological advantages I mean the
neander tals were their body plan is
adapted to colder environments that's
just like any Arctic animal they have
short the the lower part of their legs
and arms were short you can see that on
here relative to the body size whereas
modern humans Coming Out of Africa
looked they looked like um like African
mammals um for tropical mammals they had
long legs and arms which help you lose
heat in a in a very hot climate whereas
short legs and arms help you conserve
heat in a in a cold climate um neander
tals had bigger bodies which again helps
you hold in the Heat and modern humans
had more linear bodies which helps you
lose the heat so they they come into
Eurasia as tropical animals but within
about 20 25,000 years they've become
Eurasian mammals that is their legs legs
and arms get
shorter so um so they adapt to Eurasia
it takes a while but they didn't come in
with those physiological adap
is is any of that detectable from the
genetic record those kinds of uh uh
rapid as Alison is describing
physiological Transformations well um in
terms of uh the neandertal adaptation we
have some amount of sequence from a
neandertal now sadly this is riddled
with errors because of the chemical
damage that sustained DNA as it sits in
the ground for 40,000 years and um
asking the question what genetic
adaptations did the neander have is not
really possible at this time because
every place in the genome in the DNA
sequence of a neanderthal or a human
where neander tals differ from Human
it's much more likely that difference is
due to sequencing error than anything
else but what we can do kind of um
paradoxically is use the neandertal to
say more about humans we can ask how do
we differ what changes happen in US
recently even since we separated from
the Neanderthals and there's a pretty
straightforward way to do this look for
places in our genome where the
Neanderthal and the chimpanzee are the
same and where humans are different and
then those are things that have changed
recently since we split off even from
neanderthals and it's very early days
and trying to understand what regions
have changed in humans in a way that
gives us an indication that perhaps
there was an Adaptive benefit but um
coincidentally one of the genes um that
in a first past screen looking for
things where all humans have changed a
lot since we split from neandertals
turns up a gene that has to do perhaps
with this difference in bell-shaped rib
cage which um would lead one to
speculate that that may have been an
Adaptive benefit and what that means
when the when the rubber hits the road
is that if that's true that people would
have died if their rib cage was not
shaped more like the modern human or at
least they would have left less
descendants than people who had the more
archaic form which is a a strange thing
to think about how that could have
actually um increased one's Fitness
leaving more offspring or keeping you
alive when other people who had the more
bell-shaped rib cage would die well
let's do the uh adaptivity game in
Reverse um we can actually speculate as
to what say I would have looked like as
a neander tall uh we we can actually map
my characteristics onto what we
understand fan to be a neander tall
skull and get a sense of there there you
go yeah yes clearly an improvement uh
and we've taken the liberty of Doing It
With You
Allison right yeah okay I smil all right
and uh we even try to do it with you Ed
green barely had to do much there with
Ed
yeah the the question is with such a
radical difference and you're the one
who suggests the genome record indicates
that there was clearly intermingling um
can you imagine dating given those
images um what what would have brought
these characters together and what are
the circumstances where this in
intermingling might have taken place and
again it's a family
show have youever ever heard of the
Kenzie
report yeah that's just anthropology not
paleontology right yeah I I I think the
um you know the barrier of would you do
it is not uh one that we need to
consider really that obviously people
would and even um stranger things given
the opportunity we're downtown yeah I
got
you I I did see once a study and I'm uh
blank on um who did this but it was a
comparison of neander tzing features of
men and women and then asking men and
women um would you um for the for the
female neandertal eyes faces of men and
then for men of women to see if there
could have been perhaps some sex bias in
um gene flow in neanderthals and I think
the result of this was not surprising
that men probably are a little more
likely to to do this we don't see any
so it's so sad uh just but but
thankfully it's why we're all here I
guess yes there there's no I should say
seriously no um great evidence for sex
bias in the amount of AD mixture thus
far although the tests for um looking
for that are are admittedly very weak
right now there's there's not any
Smoking Gun hard evidence that it was
just neandertal men and modern human
women or the other way around there were
at least some of both do these kinds of
encounters EO Wilson produce greater
genetic diversity is this a an Adaptive
mechanism or is this more of an
accidental uh kind of thing that may or
may not confer an advantage well it's
both you know when the breakout occurred
60,000 years ago the one that really
went worldwide um there was an enormous
increase
in uh mutations of genetic diversity in
that spreading population
and it's interesting to see what the
consequences were of
that if I I can be corrected because
I've only read this so um I my
understanding is that we became the
population the uh the founder
populations that made it over and spread
then acquired a much larger diversity of
genes because it turns out uh
most of these genes were not very
obviously adaptive some were but they
mainly had to do uh or they mainly were
provided uh clear selective advantage
that is advantage in survival in two
ways one was uh increase in diet that's
the adult uh lactose tolerance genes
three times in Africa once in Eurasia
appeared and allowed dairing to occur
the other category in which we increased
greatly in our genetic diversity was
disease
resistance but correct me if I'm wrong
Ed um the uh and Chris the
um
uh the uh there was very little evidence
of
cognitive change at this
microevolutionary a single Gene change
level well we'll talk about the
cognition and sort of cultural
dimensions of this I mean it sounds like
you're you want mental propensities we
know there's an amazing thing about
human population worked out by a team of
about 50 geneticists a couple of years
ago working in 44 different countries
using the five basic personality traits
can be measured by
psychologist uh and the idea was to
compare societies all around the world
World in every continent with one
another to see if there were in fact
differences in these personality in the
distribution of these personality traits
like extroversion introversion openness
to new experience tendency to
neuroticism and so on and we know
there's a fairly Hefty level of what's
called heritability within each one of
those traits within a single population
a lot of that variation is rable that is
it's you know passes down in families
well the amazing Discovery was that
around the
world it was just about the same just
the same amount of
variation approximately in every
population around the world so this is
rather extraordinary and much varation
you wouldn't have expected all the
neurotics to be in new guine
anding people to be in Canada although
there is some evidence of that
um well uh I didn't want to go into New
York City in the very place where we
well anyway the point is although the
well the point is that uh people are
much the same around the world and we
don't know exactly why that's the case
as to why it evened out like that uh but
uh we did um go through a lot of
genetic variability change
and it same the product in the end was
pretty much the same everywhere Ed yeah
so this um they uh scans for selection
looking for regions in um our
genomes um finding genes where there has
been some adaptive benefit the sadly the
most powerful tests for doing these
contrast different groups look for local
selection so uh compare the alal
frequencies the how often different
variants in this population versus this
population sadly those can only tell you
about differences that have Arisen since
those two populations have been separate
and undergoing different selection
regimes give me a concrete example of of
some sort of characteristic that the Gen
the the poster child example of this is
the one that uh that Ed mentioned
lactase persistence and it's um uh
independently come up several times the
most well-studied perhaps instance of
this is um at high frequency in north
and west Europe um and can even be dated
using a variety of methods to something
like seven or 8 thousand years ago and
is um consistent with the archaeological
record of the onset of Daring and the it
makes a a coherent complete consistent
story that at that time there was great
need for Vitamin D and one way to get it
is to keep the gene on that can digest
the sugar in milk and drink milk as you
um suffer these terrible Winters there
and the idea is that somebody had a
mutation that figured this out
genetically they left more descendants
other people died because they didn't
have that variant the person who did
left more descendants and it came up in
frequency we can see this it stands out
like a sore thumb and the genetic
variance uh variation that exists in
that region and people in Northwest
Europe versus people um in the rest of
the world but that is a contrast that
that's describing something that
happened 7 or 8 thousand years ago
that's
that didn't help us beat the neander in
fact any genetic variant helped us beat
the neander tals and these are the
things that we can find easily uh
contrasting human populations looking
further back in time is a is a more
difficult thing Allison yeah I just like
to say while we're on the topic of
variation that the greatest human
genetic variation is in Africa only a
few Africans left Africa and gave rise
to the rest of us they were not um more
closely related to the rest of the
Africans than in fact everybody outside
of Africa is much more closely related
to one another um than to many of these
populations that stayed in Africa so the
um the these subsequent variations that
developed are very very interesting but
um not perhaps the bigger part of the
human variation story when you look at
the whole species they're interesting to
look at but they probably aren't
decisive and aren't responsible for the
way we are today is sort of what you're
saying well they're responsible for the
way some of us are today those of us who
who could who drank milk yeah for those
of us who yeah Chris I mean something
that might be relevant put Ed on the
spot really um the it was said that
there are some differences maybe in
neurotransmitters between the the modern
and the Neal genome is that significant
do you think um would love to know the
answer to that question so one of the
big open questions of a research topic
that my group and several groups are
working on is what was the function what
was the Adaptive benefit when we can see
some sign for adaptive benefit in humans
versus neanderthals it's a pretty
straightforward conceptually thing to do
to look at the variation of all humans
we get more and more and more DNA
sequence data we have one estimate was
30,000 complete human genomes have been
sequen now and many thousands of these
are publicly available anybody can look
at them you can go home and download
them on your computer now so we can look
at where every human that you look at is
different from this neander and these
are enriched for Regions where something
came up that was so important that in
our history that you would die if you
didn't have it and it came to fixation
and and we're trying to make sense of
many of these some of them may are are
in um genes that have been linked to
neural development one um big caveat
over interpreting any of this is uh uh
to to be honest about my profession that
we don't know what most genes do and
it's a sad thing to say this as a
geneticist but there are about 20 25,000
genes we can't even agree exactly on
what that number is in the human genome
and most of them we might have some clue
as to what they do because we have um
inactivated homus Gene in a fly or in
yeast and have some idea what it it's
involved with or there may be people
walking around today who have a
naturally occurring variant in this that
alters slightly the function of the Gene
and we can see what the the disease
manifestation of that is but most genes
there is very very little data about
what they do so we can screen across the
genome and say well this region that has
these genes may have been seel uh uh
undergone positive selection but what
those genes do um is is a a hard
question to answer much less what the
Adaptive benefit in this light variant
is but there's a lot to work the bad
news is there's not a lot of clarity the
good news is it's really easy to get
published on a lot of information right
yeah we have a joke that you can just
put in the anders Hall in the title of
any paper and it goes into nature of
science it it doesn't work for the non-
geneticist I have to look um yeah you
know uh before let's come out of the
Fever Swamp of population genetics and
ask a question seing that's and seeking
the reason why the Neanderthal didn't
make it speak to the diet of the
mandal weren't they specialist on
hunting and and meat eating that's more
a question for Chris they
well I mean I'm just we we could eat a
lot of different things and we were more
vegetarian is that possible I I would I
mean Allison can come in and add hers to
this but from my point of view yes I
mean modern humans broadened the diet
even more than the Andals so um aquatic
processing Marine Resources neand did a
little bit of this but it wasn't a major
what's aquatic processing is that
fishing yeah for God's sake sorry I'm
slipping into Harvard speak I apologize
more Harvard speak there I'm sorry
that's torture yeah yeah fishy very good
what do you say we do some aquatic
processing
huh I'm using worms all right anyway
sorry I I still have not heard the
answer to my
question BR brda what BR processing of
many different kinds of foods and with
modern humans you've got things like
traps and snares and Nets and these help
you gather food in all kinds of ways
which NEOS probably couldn't and I'm
sure Alison could add to this I think
they were more efficient at getting
their food but I'm not entirely
convinced that they were eating
different things I think in within
modern humans today if you look at
hunter gatherers you if you go from very
arid environments to slightly less arid
environments in arid environments the
meat consumption is higher because there
are long periods of the year when
there's nothing else to eat um and if
you go say to the edge of the desert
there's more veget vegetables that are
available year round if you look at
Arctic populations vers versus North
Boreal populations the people who live
in places where there are vegetables
always eat them and what we find we
thought that neander tals were basically
exclusive carnivores which seems
improbable because if you actually try
to live has anybody ever gone on the
scarel diet or the AC if you try to live
on
protein um you lose weight because you
simply aren't um you don't you're not
creating enough or priming the digestive
mechanism that allows you to digest all
that protein so what happens you have
terrible stomach upset and you lose
weight and it's not healthy it's a
strain on kidney function it's a strain
on everything so um they couldn't have
been if they're humans or related to us
they could not have lived only on meat
and indeed we we discovered this is
research I did with one of my students
um discovered that if you uh don't go to
a
dentist um the stuff builds up on your
teeth right you get all this uh the
plaque turns into tartar it's very hard
and you did this to one of your students
and the dentist no we we borrow Dental
piics from my dentist and we went off to
scrape the teeth of first modern humans
then old modern humans and then old
neander tals and discovered that the
starch grains from what you ate are
still on your teeth 100,000 130,000
years
later and um so this is how we
discovered that neander TS not only were
eating plants but they were cooking them
and in Iraq for instance neander tals
were eating barley
porridge in uh and we thought well maybe
that's just the ones who lived in the
Middle East where the climate was really
good but we also discovered that Belgian
neandertals who lived on the edge of the
ice were eating water lily
boots and uh beans and all kinds of
plants in fact everywhere we find that
the grasses the the wheat The Barley the
Rye the whatever form a considerable
percentage in fact the majority of the
starch grains we find on the tee and
that they all eat legumes like beans and
peas and underground storage organs like
tubers or carrots or turnips or whatever
and is this is this evidence of of a
diet managed through agriculture or pure
opportunism purely wild food no
agriculture but that neander that's the
plant component of the anderl diet was
not tiny and we're trying to figure out
why other tests are telling us that they
ate a lot of meat they probably did eat
a lot of meat in some seasons of year
but they certainly U consumed plants
whenever they could all right so it's
not it's not diet is the is is the short
answer go ahead Alison but I do think
the N the modern humans had technology
as Chris was implying that allowed them
to get a more consistent
reliable uh balanced diet they weren't
they were out competing in the Ander
tals on getting the food now where're as
in our culture in our period here in the
21st century technology may be a marker
for brains being turned off uh in fact
technology in the period that you're
talking about implies triggers of
cognition Consciousness and culture that
I suspect we like to think of as an
advantage for Homo sapiens but what do
anthropologists think about cognition
culture and uh you know these these
these questions of of Technology use
Chris um well yeah I think that one
thing that modern humans did and it's
more a social thing really um was was
you know we're great networkers and I
think that that gave us an advantage so
if we look at the the archaeological
record and I'm I'm sort of getting onto
territory here again but um you know
there there are long periods of what you
could call relatively slow change in the
stone tours through hundreds of
thousands of years then when we get to
modern humans particularly in the last
100,000 years we do see certainly a
buildup of more rapid change and I think
that that reflects social changes
because archaic humans even probably
including the anti extent were living
locally in smaller numbers and they
weren't networking to the extent across
the landscape with with their with other
groups modern humans increasingly in
Africa and then exported from Africa are
living more densely and networking
covering wider ranges in trading with
each other signaling to each other with
shell beads and red ochre probably
pigments and this means that good ideas
can take hold and spread and that's what
we find today good ideas today are
conserved and they spread like wildfire
um that's because there are lots of us
and loads of ways of storing the
information and it wasn't like that in
the past but when you get to modern
humans we start to see that accumulation
of ideas within groups because they're
networking with each other and also
there's a much greater generational
transfer it's not to we get to modern
humans that you find a lot of old people
preserved in the fossil record um so the
good news is for for the elderly that
that they were certainly useful in
elderly were a marker that that culture
was actually happening can we be more
precise about when culture began other
than tools kind of going viral uh well
well I think that you see different
aspects of behavior changing over time
and we keep pushing these these things
back so um yes as Chris mentioned we
have if we if if we work backward from
the time when modern humans have taken
over in Europe and the neandertals are
essentially disappearing that's the
period in Europe where we have the great
cave paintings I don't know if um and
um some of the things that we think of
as the the the sort of Acme of of uh
Stone Age achievement um what are we
looking at here what we're looking at
here is a painting from grat chave in
France in the ardesh and these are dated
to somewhere in the early 30,000 maybe
30 32 to 35 somewhere in there um our
radiocarbon dates are less precise than
we'd like them to be these days because
there's a big argument about how to
prepare the samples before you get to
the date um but this is an extraordinary
painting of lionesses um probably
hunting and it's in a cave that is a
treasure Trove of paintings like this
and um we have evidence of all kinds of
images and um there's been an argument
that this was an explosive development
after humans left
um Africa and confronted the cold
weather I have um Russian colleagues who
not surprisingly think you have to have
cold weather to develop a fully modern
culture well but of course you do yes
but the the fact is and I have another
uh picture from um a different part of
the world from approximately the same
age um this is a painting of a human
notice that the legs on the left are
human and the the creature to on the
right is an animal so it's a a human who
seems to be transforming into an animal
and that's a very common theme we find
in this very early art and where is this
from this this is from
Namibia in Southwest Africa it's also
30,000 years old or a little bit older
it's recently been redated to that time
period and um there there are a couple
of images from that cave like this and
then there's another one that is working
its way to
publication um and I think these are in
a a late Middle Stone Age type uh
setting but they are dated to more or
less the same ballpark as the Chauvet
paintings but at the other end of the
world so what this says to me is that
the people who left Africa were part of
a tradition that could do this if they
had to this isn't something that
developed among the PE only among the
people who left this was already there
so then we have to go back and say where
did this begin and if we go back before
this we see that um there are not images
before this but they are geometric
designs on ochre and there are shell
beads MH and so so artifacts costume
artifacts indicate a a a culture trigger
taking place and these are where are
these from here these are from the
southern tip of Africa at a place called
blombos which is right where Africa
comes to a point down at the bottom and
if you look at them very carefully you
can see I don't know if you can see this
in the in the picture but um one of the
things about these shells is that
they've all been perforated in a place
that would enable them to be strong but
it isn't a good place if you're a marine
uh snail Predator interested in eating
another snail you're not going to make a
hole in its lip because you're not going
to get to the other snail that way
you're going to go for the for the body
so these are um
possibly uh arguably maybe the
perforations are made by humans but what
we can see in these perforations is that
they're all polished on one Edge
particularly the one in the upper right
um has a polished Edge that can only
come from wearing it on a
string for a long time and they also
have some microscopic traces of red
ochre on them which come from wearing
the Mona string on a body that has red
ochre paint on it so it's quite likely
that these are people who had a very
rich array of symbols that told you in
as soon as you saw them who they were
and they said I'm a whoever I'm a
southern African from Pinnacle Point
date this for us and this is also this
is um about the same age as the be it's
about 70 75,000 years old and so this is
one of these geometric
designs um and there are several others
from this cave and other sites where we
have some sort of GE of design it's not
an image that we recognize as an animal
but it's a design that's been placed on
a little slab of ochre about this
big and the argument here is that people
are making durable symbols in some way
that carry information information about
who they are or about um something in
their world that was important and the
fact that they are able to walk around
with these symbols on them or to leave
them in places where other humans are
going to come along and find them and
say you know it's like killroy was here
uh and you know it sort of says it might
have said the beads might have said I'm
married you can't have me or it might
have said um I'm a big Chief and or a
big uh important person or purely
marking territory or just marking
territory and I think it's just worth
saying that this in a sense doesn't do
justice to the object because when that
was freshly done it would have been a
vivid red blood red you know color right
there the end or Soul art we we can go
back in Africa um one of the things I I
just wanted wanted to say from some of
the work that my colleagues and I have
been doing we can now go back in Africa
and find the shell beads go back to um
90 100,000 years ago um they're this
it's more or less the same kind of shell
all over Africa and into the Middle East
but um it doesn't really mean that it's
not a symbol of identity because you
could arrange the shell in a different
way as people do today with glass beads
that are the same all over the world but
the design is what matters and um the
other thing is we find OCH not
necessarily with designs on it but ochre
that has been ground on a grindstone
into powder um much much earlier even
before we have Homo sapiens we have
sites with kilos or pounds and pounds
and kilos of ochre that somebody has
brought in and it's usually uh
preferentially red ochre or sometimes
purple but never or much more rarely is
it yellow ochre and we're testing the
ochr and finding they're all pretty much
effective for any technological use you
can think of for ochre but let's
speculate on what those uses would be
are we are we talking about a medium for
uh making durable markings drawings
images costuming Cosmetics well ochre
can also make um AAA gum elastic so that
you can half an arrow or a spear Point
onto a half but it turns out and we have
these these Arrow points with ochre
traces on them but it turns out that
yellow ochre is just as good as red
ochre for this purpose it's something
some experiments we've been doing this
year uh but the red ochre is is almost
always preferred and often from very
distant sources let's step back for a
moment and try to ask the question what
was going on you say there's now
evidence of some sort of cultural uh
emergence uh that goes back before
neander TS vanished um that suggests
that uh there was a a a cultural trigger
that took place maybe 100 thousand years
ago maybe more um can we ask the
question the species that developed
culture first had an obvious advantage
over the others and that was going to
determine why that species survived and
the others didn't and uh Ed's question
here could neandertals have had a
culture could another species have had
culture and if they had developed it
first would they have been the winners
here is there any way to even speculate
about that Allison and then let's get a
comment from everybody culture is a very
uh difficult term to Define there are a
lot of people who would argue that
chimpanzees have culture because the
chimpanzees in one place use tools
differently or they shake hands
differently from chimpanzees in another
place but the kind of um elaborate
symbolic culture that we're talking
about only occurs in
humans and but it also theander tals did
have pigments so this is something
that's very old in humans it does go
back to
300,000 to 200 300 even 400,000 years
ago we have this in big increase in
ochre as soon as the as homo H highle
bensis probably came along um they began
developing this this kind of culture so
when theander tals left Africa they had
or when the line leading to neandertals
and Denise Evans left they had some
rudimentary ability for symbolic culture
and this is reinforced by the fact that
they also share what was thought to be
an important Gene that controls for
language so yes they were on this they
started out with the same abilities but
African humans went further in
developing them Gene for language Ed if
Fox P2 is is the gene in question here
the um this is a gene whose function is
known because there is a family in the
British Isles I think that has an
inherited disorder this family you knock
out one copy of this Gene and um the um
disease phenotype is that people have a
hard time processing speech and language
and some other more subtle aspects of
the phenotype like they have a hard time
keeping a steady Rhythm um this is
somehow
related to only having one copy active
copy of this Gene this Gene is also
interesting it was way more interesting
maybe 5 10 years ago um because if you
look at the version of this Gene Fox P2
um in humans and compare it to the
chimpanzee version there are two
differences in a region in this Gene
that's otherwise really highly conserved
even out to mice so mice have this Gene
the function of this Gene more generally
is that it binds DNA and turns on other
genes so it's one of these Regulators of
Gene function so it has some crucial
differences perhaps even since
chimpanzees and we know something uh
that it's related to speech and language
it's one of the first things we wanted
to look at in the Ander tals in fact we
went and pulled out the DNA for this
Gene before we even got the genome and
found quite to our surprise that these
two differences are shared with the
neander tals and we know now they're
also shared with the Denise Evin so
whatever um whatever benefit toward
speech and language this Gene confers
was shared with the neander tals but
having said that speech and language are
almost certainly they are um multigenic
highly complex traits that aren't just
the result of a single Gene so um if
neander it's a it's a huge interesting
open question and I would love to hear
everyone else's opinion about this
whether or not neander TOS could talk
and is this the conduit of um networking
of cultural transmission that that and
vision um if they could talk then um
perhaps that's not the reason why we
beat them but if they couldn't then it's
an obvious candidate and that's not my
idea that idea has been around for a
long time that that they were deficient
in this way and we were not and it was
you if you think about all the things
that you know and um calculate how much
of that you figured out yourself versus
was told to you it's obvious how
important this is speech and language
and and being able communicate through
language it's what makes us so
incredible word Neanderthal is
incredible in that way
too which came first Society or the
language Chris well I think they evolved
together really I I mean my view is that
language evolved out of out of social
interaction and social complexity and uh
I yeah I think the anatar must have had
some form of language um as we've heard
they're using pigments they're they're
well adapted to their environment um
they're burying their dead I mean
they're ref few people who doubt that
but I think they were burying their dead
and that level of complexity I I think
you have to give them language but of
course it's difficult for us to envisage
another kind of human and another kind
of language when there's a gulf between
us and chimpanzees but 100,000 years ago
there were these other species around
and theand hols had evolv separately
from us for several hundred thousand
years as Allison said I think both
groups both species as i' would call
them were going down the road of
increasing complexity but we went
further down that road so what was the
accelerator for modern humans was it was
it population density was it language EO
Wilson well let's now introduce I mean
this has been brilliant I've learned
more from these people than I uh you
know that's not in most of the journals
I've been looking at and it's just
wonderful new insights has dispelled
possible hypotheses have been
circulating along but I want to bring up
the dark side
the dark side is group
competition and when you look at the
historical record and then traces of
what might have been going on even into
preh humans uh we find um that we are
intensely an intensely aggressive
species and that group uh uh group
conflict is fundamental to humans
leading up to constant episodes of
tribal replacement genocide and so on
and we know coming back now to the
driving force of of social Evolution
that there would appear the group
selection is a very important fact of
the Argin at least the homo sapiens and
what does that do in its consequences
well a number of things intense group
selection group against group would
include the development of a couple of
traits which would include the tend you
know the tenden or intern
interneting uh uh networking and also of
um a um uh an intense two things that
are intense uh it's intensely human in
modern humans that could be a result of
this one is that we are extremely group
conscious we must belong to a group we
form groups quickly we know from
psychological test that people uh as a
for any excuse will form a group and
when you form them and when you say
group you mean different than kinship
grp that distinguishes
your aggre familial
or Beyond uh from other groups and
psychologists have run experiments in
which they've set up arbitrarily chosen
groups that is membership is arbitrary
and Ransom and as soon as they set up a
group group even in a simple simple uh
experimental situation uh people quickly
uh identify readly with that group and
come to regard the other randomly
created group in playing simple games as
suspicious so so the propensity here in
New York to say so so the the qualities
here in New York of saying the people in
the meat district are cooler than the
people on the upper east side and the
people of Brooklyn are cool and all the
rest that's actually an
evolutionary that is that is feature of
of Humanity General it's a general
quality of group isness that is to say
uh seriously we are constantly in the
process of forming groups of expressing
loyalty to groups and this is uh I think
the uh one of the products of intense
group selection which involves
aggression among groups the other one uh
that's developed is our intense interest
in each other that is humans been an
enormous amount of time uh trying to
figure out what other people in their
group is doing and judging uh Gossip is
an extremely important adaptive you know
phenomenon well we think these are so
natural to us uh that we didn't we don't
think of them really as evolved adaptive
trait and I'll just bring that up then
uh that this could be one of the
products of an extreme aggressiveness
that homo sapiens had that maybe our uh
other homine Rivals did not have do
think I just throw that in and I would
love to hear what the experts here
present uh say about that I I uh I have
a slightly different take on the on the
group isness issue I I think that what
humans um if you look at what we were
doing at the time of the exit from
Africa versus what NE anals were doing
one of the really striking things is
that for a couple of hundred, years at
the at that point we had been developing
social
networks and the way we trace this on
the ground is by looking at how far
people are going to get the stone
they're making their stone tools out of
after all we don't have much uh material
to work with here we don't have the
people we don't have the uh DNA most of
the time text messages are gone text
messages are gone right no no email so
so um what we're seeing is that
beginning before let's say 340 to
400,000 years ago around then um people
are beginning to bring in Stone from
considerable distances on a regular
basis um 50 60 70 100 kilometers away um
The Stone is coming in on not just a
piece here and there not just a finish
tool here and there but masses of it and
this is implying that there's a network
a supply network going in a bunch of
different directions that you've
negotiated the right to go to someone
else's territory because those are much
bigger than a typical human foraging
range would be to go to someone else's
territory and get some of their Stone
you you have to uh you'd have to let
them know before that they shot you log
in get a password friend and not a foe
so we also see this is when the pigment
comes in as well so I think we're seeing
a completely different approach to
social
organization in the H in the modern
humans than and these aren't even modern
humans yet um than we're seeing in the
Neals Neals simply did not do this so
they they don't have these long-distance
contacts and I I actually have a
colleague who thinks that neander talls
may have had the ability to form a
language but they didn't have the same
Vocal Track that we have so they
couldn't make uh the same kinds of I
don't know what Chris thinks about this
but the the the sounds may have been a
little bit less distinct so I asked um
one of these guys once well what did you
think the neeral sounded like what would
it have been like talking to a
neandertal and he said did you ever talk
to a
2-year-old would have been like talking
to a 2-year-old only his mother can
really understand him so um you know
neandertals might not have been uh as as
fasil at making friends who lived a
considerable distance away and had a
different accent although I do have a
two-year-old who's evolving very quickly
at home now and before I go back to uh
see him um let's have a conclusionary
thought here on the question of how well
we're doing as uh you know residents of
this planet seven billion of us um do we
see the adaptations and what's going on
now as a sign of success uh obviously
population is a sign of success but you
know are there signs of us possibly
making some of the same mistakes or
experiencing some of the same stresses
that you have observed in early humans
in a very very different setting on the
planet how do you think we're doing Ed
well I think just in terms of census
population size we're off the rails this
is unprecedented if you compare um
current humans with all previous humans
and what we think their census
population sizes are and all other great
apes who are alive today it is uh um you
know the really big brain revenge of the
nerd story there's s billion of us and
maybe 100,000 of the most populous great
ape those got not only we crowded out
all the other homin forms but we're on
our way to crowding out all the other
great apes and so our biggest danger
right now is really our success I guess
and and that um we are taxing um people
hear this all the time and it sounds
priy but we're taxing the world in a way
that it's never been done before so um
hopefully we're smart enough to figure
out a solution to that problem at lunch
today Alice Alison you said that Darwin
had something to say about the Prospect
of humans coexisting with perhaps other
similar species and that the that seemed
very very unlikely uh in your view based
on our history in answering the same
question that Ed answered uh do you see
the possibility of of us coexisting with
another species is is the fossil record
an indication that we're good at that
sort of thing or is pretty much the Big
D dominance all we do as Homo sapiens I
don't think that um that we do well at
coexistence I mean if you think about
what we do to even other populations of
our own species when you meet another
population there ends up being one group
that dominates the other either as they
enslave them they resign them to a lower
cast they form some kind of very
specialized symbiotic relationship where
one group of um humans from one group
looks down on the other one so there's
always an asymmetry when two modern
human groups meet and you have to think
what would happen if it were really
another species so were the other
species kind of like the peaceful
hippies and we are much more the
aggressive must dominate or is that a
feature of hominids generally that there
can be no stalemate based on what you've
studied I think well in in some ways um
it doesn't seem that we're we're born to
be peaceful hippies I have to say sadly
um that uh it it just we can try um and
maybe we can
succeed but it hasn't happened very
often in the past Chris think that's
sory um well something even more
controversial than uh than human
evolution and and population size is
because climate change and I do think
that in the immediate future that that's
you know a really huge threat to us um
and uh we need to do something about
that or human numbers will be very
seriously threatened in the future we're
going to go through I mean we've seen
lots of climate change in the past and
humans have got through it but we're
heading into new territory with the
predicted Rises people are talking about
you know large areas of the tropics and
subtropics could end up being being
uninhabitable so that will drastically
change our future and I think you know
I'm somebody who believes that that
really is a threat and some of the same
dramas and stresses that you've observed
as a paleoanthropologist may be in our
future even all seven billion of us yo
Wilson take us out what do you think how
are we doing well we're an extremely
aggressive species and uh that
aggressive uh displacement of
populations even of our own uh
genotype uh exists along with the long
uh trading routes you mentioned it's uh
they are consistent genocide accompanies
uh the trading or is preceded by it or
goes along with it it's a
kaleidoscope of aggression alliances
constantly changing borders uh is um
William James said history is a blood
bath and we should see that as a
powerful generating Force for what we
are uh if that trait is specific to our
species as opposed to those competitors
that fell before us uh that could
explain a lot and until we know exactly
what uh with the origin of those
patterns and how extensive they were
going back into prehistory uh we may not
have uh a definitive answer of why we
now stand alone but what is also
worrisome as we see our population
rising to 10 billion but then probably
peing and starting to come down by the
end of the century is that we are in the
same manner destroying the rest of life
such that by the end of the century if
we don't rain in now we will lose up to
half of the species of plants and
animals on Earth so we are very Reckless
uh we are off the rails that's true uh
we are a mix of
wonderful virtuous and also murderous
traits and we scarcely begun to
understand why that is so and that would
be the bad news but the good news might
be that if we don't make it as uh humans
Homo sapiens and the planet survives the
paleoanthropologists of the future are
going to have a whole hell of a lot of
fossils and stuff to deal with they're
going to have a party that's for sure
Chris Stringer Ed green Allison Brooks
and EO Wilson thanks so
much I thanks to all of you this been
[Applause]
[Music]
great
n
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh